[Music]
they're not taking these cases seriously
if they were
they would be not just settling but
changing their policies strong words
there from the lawyer of a Clark County
School District student fed up with
administrators that student now suing
CCSD for failing to protect him from
bullying now that student is also suing
the other students parents who he says
bullied him the victim's attorney says
coming after the parents is a way to
hold the kids accountable all new here
at six o'clock Joshua peguero Joins us
live in The Newsroom with more on this
case Joshua now CCSD says it does not
respond to ongoing litigation but in
this complaint 17-year-old Nicholas
Monroe says he was brutally beaten by
three students at basic Academy of
international studies and when he sought
the district's help he says they failed
to protect him
it started online through social media
app Instagram and it it progressed into
actual bullying at school as well
Nicholas Monroe alleges The Bullying
began as he was entering his freshman
year at basic Academy I went up to the
school multiple times multiple days in a
row just saying hey
um I've been threatened I've been
threatened and it just it was never
resolved three students are named in the
lawsuit we are not naming them because
they are miners the lawsuit says the
teens caused injuries to Nicholas
Monroe's head neck shoulders chest back
legs hips knees ankles and extremities
Monroe said he suffered a brain injury
they couldn't secure my safety so I had
to transfer out to some somewhere that
would secure my safety to the Charter
schooling Monroe is now asking the
parents of each of the students a cost
of ten thousand dollars each that covers
the fifteen thousand dollars he's
incurred in medical expenses plus money
for psychological critical distress
Monroe's attorney Jacob Levitt says
parents need to be held accountable for
their child's Behavior I was born and
raised here I'm here I would love to see
Clark County School District
actually take action and protect these
children Levitt tells me every week he
gets 10 inquiries from students looking
to sue bullies and their parents while
he can ask the jury for millions of
dollars Levis says CCSD legally wouldn't
have to pay up you have a school
district who who takes the approach of
hey here's our maximum
we're we're protected by the legislature
that we don't have to pay above a
hundred thousand dollars so what do we
care that's our worst day in court
now the teens and their parents don't
have a lawyer list on court records and
according to Levitt the three teens are
facing charges related to the injuries
reporting live in The Newsroom Joshua
pregu 8 News Now